bethenny frankel announced she's leaving
the Real Housewives and the news came as
a shock to everybody even her co-stars
are we not talking about the elephant in
the room or in the beach Bethenny's
heartfelt message to her fans is hair ah
that's the Bethenny we're gonna miss her
surprising exit from the Real Housewives
of New York confirmed in a statement to
ET and gave her reasons why it's time to
move on and focus on my daughter and my
philanthropy
she's also producing TV shows with Mark
Burnett I do things that I enjoy and I
don't setup unrealistic expectations her
cast mates were blindsided by her exit
Ramona Singer tells ET I think it's
strange that me and the other cast
members had to read about it in the
press instead of hearing it from her
directly by text wow did LuAnn de
Lesseps exclusively tells et we had our
ups and downs I choose to remember the
ups this is the second time the 48 year
old has left the franchise she
originally left in 2010 I liked a little
party when it's still fun she's walking
away from a reported million dollar per
season paycheck so we think she's got
plenty of left over from when she sold
her Skinnygirl brand in 2011 for a
reported 100 million dollars and she's
moved on from the death of her late
boyfriend in his shields last year with
film producer and real estate exact all
burning I am a lucky lucky lady
but for now let's pay our respects with
some of our favorite Bethenny moments
pinching it off
my job
[Music]